mientras el mundo concentra sus
esfuerzos en la vacunación para frenar
la expansión del nuevo corona virus la
oms advierte que millones de niños están
expuestos a la contracción de otras
enfermedades tan mortales como evitables
sobre todo en áfrica levas existir y que
a pesar que las vacunas contra el coi 19
nos dan esperanza al final del túnel la
pandemia ha provocado múltiples
perturbaciones en los servicios de
inmunización alrededor del mundo round
the world
y nuevos datos de la ong se muestran que
como resultado del 1960 campañas de
inmunización están actualmente
suspendidas en 50 países fifty countries
that means eso significa que cerca de
228 millones de niños son vulnerables
actualmente a enfermedades prevenibles
tales como el sarampión la fiebre
amarilla o la polio isla meals yellow
fever en polio
segúnla o ms de las 60 campañas pausadas
casi la mitad son contra el sarampión
una de las patologías más contagiosas y
que causa una mayor mortalidad infantil
desde hace 50 años se dispone de fármaco
para prevenirla
en 2016 el 85% de los niños y niñas del
mundo recibieron la vacuna antes de
cumplir un año naciones unidas- indica
que esta inmunización generalizada salvó
más de 20 millones de vidas entre 2000 y
2016 pero desde entonces los casos han
vuelto a aumentar
incluso antes de la pandemia ya estamos
perdiendo terreno en la lucha contra las
enfermedades infantiles evitables
20 millones de niños y estaban quedando
fuera de una vacunación necesaria y
situaría al sarampión y la polio en la
cabeza de mi lista
y ahora un año después del inicio de la
pandemia de kobe 19 seguimos perdiendo
terreno para revertir la tendencia la
oms anunció una nueva estrategia de
vacunación mundial con la que pretende
reducir a la mitad de 20 a 10 millones
la población infantil que no reciben
ninguna vacuna y salvar así 50 millones
de vidas para 2030